>> Laura: A MAJORITY OF THE
20-20 DEMOCRATS WERE IN SAN
FRANCISCO THE PAST WEEKEND AND
WERE SEEKING TO WIN OVER THE
VERY PROGRESSIVE DELEGATES OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CONVENTION.
BUT AT WHAT COST?
HERE TO ANNOUNCE THIS, POLLSTER,
FRANK LUTZ.
I WANT TO START WITH THIS.
14 OF THE CANDIDATES WERE THERE.
BUT NOTABLY ABSENT WAS THE
FRONT-RUNNER, JOE BIDEN.
AND THE COMPETITORS USED THE
OCCASION TO TAKE NOT SO THINLY
VEILED SHOTS AT HIM THROUGHOUT.
>> SOME SAY IF WE ALL JUST CALM
DOWN.
THE REPUBLICANS WILL COME TO
THEIR SENSES.
BUT OUR COUNTRY IS IN A TIME OF
CRISIS.
THE TIME FOR SMALL IDEAS IS
OVER.
>> THE RISKIEST THING WE COULD
DO IS TRY TOO HARD TO PLAY IT
SAFE.
>> WE DON'T NEED A CRIME BILL,
WE NEED A HOPE BILL.
>> THERE IS A DEBATE AMONG
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES WHO HAVE
SPOKEN TO YOU HERE IN THIS ROOM
AND THOSE WHO HAVE CHOSEN FOR
WHATEVER REASON NOT TO BE IN
THIS ROOM.
>> FRANK, DO YOU THINK BIDEN
SKIPPED THIS?
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THEM TO KIND
OF TRY TO OUTDO EACH OTHER ON
THE LEFT FRONT.
SO BIDEN CAN JUST LOOK
REASONABLE BY COMPARISON?
>> IF I WAS ADVISING HIM, I
WOULD HAVE TOLD HIM TO SKIP
THIS, THE SENATE, THE VICE
PRESIDENT, DOES NOT WANT TO BE
COMPARED TO HIS OPPONENTS UNTIL
HE GETS TO THE DEBATE STAGE.
THAT'S ONLY ABOUT 23, 24 DAYS
FROM NOW.
SO, BECAUSE THE VICE PRESIDENT
HAS SUCH A LEAD, HIS GOAL IS YOU
DON'T WANT TO BE SIDE-BY-SIDE
WITH HIM.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE COMPARED
WITH THEM.
YOU ONLY WANT TO DO IT WHEN IT
MATTERS.
SO I ACTUALLY THINK IT WAS A
GOOD STRATEGY TO SKIP
CALIFORNIA.
>> I WANT TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
WHAT THIS CROWD WAS LIKE IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
CANDIDATE JOHN DELANEY AND JOHN
HICKENLOOPER TRIED TO OFFER A
LITTLE DOSE OF REALITY.
>> IF WE WANT
>> BOO!
>> I WAS RE-ELECTED.
MEDICARE FOR ALL MAY SOUND GOOD.
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY NOT GOOD
POLICY NOR IS IT GOOD POLITICS.
I'M TELLING YOU.
>> Laura: FRANK, IT SOUNDS LIKE
I WAS SPEAKING AT THE DEMOCRAT
CONVENTION IN CALIFORNIA.
THOSE GUYS HAVE NO CHANCE IN
THIS PARTY.
THEY SHOULD BOTH BECOME
REPUBLICANS.
>> THE PROBLEM NOW FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IS THAT THE CORE --
THEIR BASE VOTE -- IS SO FAR ON
THE LEFT WITH THESE POLICIES,
BUT I WANT TO REMIND VIEWERS
THIS IS A GREAT EXERCISE FOR
THEM.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T REALIZE HOW
MUCH THE DEMOCRATS HAVE CHANGED.
HOW MUCH THEIR POLICIES HAVE
MOVED TO THE LEFT.
AND ON EVERY SINGLE ISSUE, THE
ACTIVIST CAN'T WAIT TO BOO THE
MODERATES IN THE PARTY.
THIS IS JUST LIKE THE
REPUBLICANS FROM 2016, IT'S JUST
A MIRROR IMAGE ON THE LEFT.
>> AND, OF COURSE, NO CONFAB IN
SAN FRANCISCO WOULD BE COMPLETE
WITHOUT SAN FRANCISCO GRAND NAN
POPPING IN.
THAT'S NANCY PELOSI.
THEREON THE CROWD WHEN SHE TALKS
TRUMP.
>> SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER
WARNED US THERE WAS AN ATTACK ON
OUR ELECTIONS.
WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT COVERING
UP?
THIS IS NOT ABOUT POLITICS THIS,
IS ABOUT PATRIOTISM.
WE WILL GO WHERE THE FACTS LEAD
US.
WE WILL INSIST ON THE TRUTH.
WE WILL BUILD ON AN IRONCLAD
CASE TO ACT.
>> WELL, THEY'RE SCREAMING
IMPEACH, IMPEACH, IMPEACH,
FRANK.
>> WELL, LOOK, THIS IS NOW THE
CENTER, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
MOVED TO THE LEFT OF NANCY
PELOSI.
IT WILL BE A CHALLENGE FOR THEM
TO MOVE BACK AFTER THE ELECTION.
THIS MAKES PERFECT SENSE.
THIS IS THE PRIMARY VOTER, THE
CAUCUS VOTER.